schauen wir nach Deutschland und auch da
keine guten Aussichten für 2023 düstere
Aussichten in einer Zeit in der die
Menschen ohnehin schon in der Krise
stecken nächste Woche stellt
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck die
Prognosen für das nächste Jahr vor und
Bild liegen jetzt exklusiv die Zahlen
vor
die Konjunktur bricht ein die deutsche
Wirtschaft schmiert ab und dazu der
nächste teuerschock 2023 wird noch
schlimmer Bild liegen exklusiv die
Zahlen vor die Wirtschaftsminister
Robert Habeck erst nächste Woche
vorstellen will es sind
besorgniserregende zahlen die deutsche
Wirtschaft sie wächst 2023 nicht die
schrumpft und zwar um
0,4%. und der teuer Schock er wird sogar
noch schlimmer als dieses Jahr die
Inflation
8%. die Arbeitslosigkeit steigt von 5,2
auf
5,4%. Konjunktureinbruch mehr
Arbeitslosigkeit hohe Preise düstere
Aussichten für 2023
[Musik]
und dazu bei uns im Studio unser
bildpolitikchef Jan Schäfer grüße Dich
Jan 0,4 Prozent Minus das klingt erstmal
gar nicht so dramatisch warum ist das
aber ganz dramatisch -0,4 es ist
dramatisch weil die Wirtschaftsleistung
schrumpft und wenn die Wirtschaft
schrumpft bedeutet das am Ende auch
immer das weniger waren hier gestellt
werden dass wir davon ausgehen müssen
dass auch Beschäftigte ihren
Arbeitsplatz verlieren wir müssen uns
einmal vergegenwärtigen noch im Frühjahr
war man ausgegangen von ungefähr 2,5%
Wirtschaftswachstum im nächsten Jahr und
jetzt also ein deutlicher deutlicher
Rückschritt wir sehen das auch in ersten
Zahlen die es gibt für das abgelaufene
Quartal und die Prognosen auch von
anderen Instituten also im nächsten Jahr
geht es auf jeden Fall runter und das
Interessante ist ja das was wir bis
jetzt wissen dass sich diese ganzen
Prognosen eigentlich eher auf ein
einigermaßen gutes energieumfeld Stützen
sprich die gasmangelage und das wird gar
nicht zu einem gravierenden gasmangel
kommen wir wissen aber wenn das passiert
also wenn das wirklich knapp werden
sollte dann wird der wirtschaftsabsturz
möglicherweise noch viel viel größer und
es gab ja Institute die gesagt haben
dann gehen wir runter auf -6 - 7
vielleicht sogar -8% im nächsten Jahr
wie steuert man da jetzt gegen also hat
man schon Pläne weil wir sehen ja jetzt
alles schon wie die Menschen ja
sozusagen an dieser Krise in dieser
Krise leiden wie versucht man da jetzt
schon eventuell gegenzusteuern die
Bundesregierung ist ja heftig dabei ein
weiteres entlastungsprogramm auf den Weg
zu bringen dieser sogenannte
Abwehrschirm in einem Volumen von
ungefähr 200 Milliarden Euro der dazu
beitragen soll das Gaspreise
beispielsweise gedeckelt werden oder
auch Firmen die in Not geraten
Energieversorger dann vom Staat
aufgefangen werden oder ein Staatskredit
erhalten können das ist ein großes
großes Programm Olaf Scholz hat jüngst
das ganze was es bisher an Programmen
gibt die ganzen Hilfsprogramme gegen
diese Energiekrise auf fast 300
Milliarden Euro mittlerweile schon
beziffert also das ist wirklich schon
ein sehr sehr großes Paket er sprach er
selbst von einem und jetzt müssen wir
einfach mal abwarten reicht das am Ende
immer wieder wichtig zu sagen alles was
man jetzt zusätzlich ausgibt muss man
als Steuerzahler irgendwann auch wieder
zurück bezahlen von daher ist das
eigentlich nur Zeit kaufen mit dem
eigenen Geld so stark wird die
Wirtschaft im nächsten Jahr schrumpfen
die Zahlen kennt ihr schon kennst du
schon unser Bild politik-chef Jan
Schäfer bleibt noch ein Klammer mit
bounce wir wollen auf die
chaos-hauptstadt schauen hier auf Berlin
immer wieder Kopfschütteln ja über all
das was wir alles schief läuft in der
Hauptstadt und heute dann diese drei
neuen berlin-geschichten ja wirklich zum
Kopfschütteln ein Berliner
Doppeldeckerbus der sich an einer Brücke
die obere Etage abrasiert weil der
Busfahrer offenbar eine Abkürzung
gefahren ist dann gibt es noch ein
großes lichtfestival das Festival of
light in der Hauptstadt und das obwohl
die Bürgermeisterin Giffey alle Berliner
zum Bahn auf ja und dann das ein
Berliner Polizeibeamter der sich auf der
Straße Koks kauft und die Polizei in
Berlin muss das auch noch zugeben mit
diesem Tweet hier nämlich unglaubliche
Geschichte also eine von diesen drei
unglaublichen berlin-stories die
Berliner Polizei die zugeben muss dass
einer ihrer lka-bahn und auf der Straße
sich bei einem Drogen Kurier Kokain
besorgt hat das ist Berlin
schauen wir aber auf das Festival of
Lights Jan Schäfer bei uns noch im
Studio ja wir hören die ganze Zeit spart
Strom spart Energie macht das Licht aus
duscht weniger also all diese schönen
Binsenweisheiten und dann das Festival
of light eigentlich eine schöne Sache
alles wird ein bisschen nett angestrahlt
aber man denkt doch einfach so das ist
doch völlig unnötig also muss einmal
klar zu sagen es ist eine wirklich
schöne Sache dieses Festival of Lights
es ist bloß ein bisschen verwunderlich
das ausgerechnet diejenige nämlich die
Regierende Bürgermeisterin hier in
Berlin Franziska Giffey Schirmherren des
Festivals ist und vor drei Wochen ja
noch gesagt hat ja es wird im Winter
möglicherweise echte Stromprobleme geben
hier in Berlin und dann wäre es
vertretbar wenn einzelne Stadtteile oder
Kieze wie sie gesagt hat mal für zwei
bis drei Stunden eben keinen Strom
bekommen würden und das ist das große
Problem einerseits eine Regierende
Bürgermeisterin die die Bürger darauf
einschwört dass es privat keinen Strom
geben kann dass das auch in Ordnung oder
wie sie sagt vertretbar wäre und
andererseits der Staat auch wenn dieses
Festival privat finanziert ist der seine
Bürger mit einem ja Festival beglückt
das ist eine Umkehrung dessen was wir
eigentlich an Gesellschaft haben und
wollen da steht das Individuum im
Vordergrund nicht die staatlich
verordnete Glückseligkeit und wir haben
es hier bei Frau Giffey ganz klar mit
einer stromscheinheiligen zu tun so so
kann man das glaube ich sagen also das
heißt in einigen Bezirken in Berlin geht
sozusagen das Licht aus während an den
Sehenswürdigkeiten in Berlin Mitte
weiterhin das Festival of Lights strahlt
ist ein bisschen zugespitzt jetzt aber
zumindest hat die Regierende
Bürgermeisterin die gleichzeitig wie
gesagt Schirmherrin dieses Festivals ist
ja ihre Bürger schon darauf eingestimmt
dass es im Winter zu Strom Ausfällen
staatlich verordnet kommen kann und umso
absurder ist eigentlich dass dann diese
Bürgermeisterin Schirmherrin eines
Festivals auf lights ist in dieser
aktuell angespannten Situation das ist
wirklich nicht mehr zu verstehen also
absolute Top humoral von unserer
Regierenden Bürgermeisterin Jan Schäfer
ganz herzlichen Dank an dich
[Musik]